so let me start off with uh introducing
your panelists um on my left i have nick
schrock nick is the cto and or ceo
excuse me way more important
co-founder of elemental the company
behind dagster previously nick worked at
facebook where he co-created graphql
nick believes deeply in the power of
well-designed developer tools to make
engineers more productive accelerate
their careers make their lives more
enjoyable and transform the
organizations in which they work
which i think many of us do so we've got
some some kinship one thing that i did
not know until recently about nick is
that he seriously considered a
postgraduate degree in history before
deciding to be a software engineer
next we have prakalpa sankar prakalpa is
the co-founder of atlan
a modern data collaboration workspace
which acts as a virtual hub for data
assets ranging from tables and
dashboards to models and code atlan
enables teams to create and discover a
discovery and context layer for all
their data assets
previously she co-founded the data for
good company and economic forum tech
pioneer social cops
which is behind landmark data projects
including india's national data platform
uh fun fact pracalpa is the only
proculpa in the world
it's true my parents thought of seo
before seo existed
sri shankar das from ackrel is here he's
the co-founder and ceo uh ackroel is the
company behind the open source metadata
platform data hub
in collaboration with linkedin
prior to founding acura sri shanka spent
a decade at linkedin building data
infrastructure and data platforms he
also founded the data hub project as
part of his tenure there
and finally we have stephen hillian from
astronomer steven is head of data at
astronomer and before that he built
machining learning platforms at a series
of silicon valley startups including
including pivotal and alpine data
he's served up predictive models to
clients ranging from abc to wendy's and
as a fun fact he's currently working on
a translation of the corpus of greek
mathematical poems
yes make sure to pre-order that on
amazon
i feel much less interested now
i have a fun fact oh please
i did not have a fun fact but
i was brave enough to interview a 10
year old about metadata
is amazing um
that is absolutely a sign of bravery now
metadata obviously is a key part of data
sets um but not the only one data sets i
think we can all agree are absolutely
foundational to our work as data
practitioners
we use that word all the time when we're
describing our day-to-day conversations
of projects that we're working on
there are a lot of different data tools
that have independently converged on
similar concepts but like many of the
concepts in the modern data stack
the exact meaning properties and
capabilities of data sets often differs
in subtle ways and we see a lot of
competing terms that are vying for
attention as the
critical artifact in our world
i absolutely believe that concepts like
this will define the next generation of
data work
and um that the cornerstone of the
modern data stack is a new set of tools
and abstractions that map more tightly
to the world in which we all work
so let me start off with a with an open
question in the interest of of
disclosure can i have each of you
describe a little bit about your project
your work project and how you think that
shapes your concept of a data set
yeah i'll start off um so
work on dagster which is the data
orchestration platform
and
we it
grounds the definition of our our
definition of data set because we view
as a data asset which we'll get into and
we think that the data asset is
fundamentally a software artifact
that you should model in the
orchestrator and be its source of truth
um hi um so in atlanta we sort of see
ourselves as that collaborative layer
for the data stack in some ways and i
think the fundamental thing that we
believe is about diversity right if you
think about number on a dashboard is
broken i have to remember this as a data
leader myself cabinet minister calls me
at eight in the morning and says number
on this dashboard doesn't look right and
then i call my project manager who calls
my analyst who calls my engineer
takes like five different calls like
eight hours to even figure out what went
wrong
and the core to the data stack is this
layer of diversity right like diversity
is never going away diversity in the
kinds of people and personas and
diversity in the kind of tools that each
of these personas are using and so then
if you think about what does it take to
sort of achieve that collaborative layer
in a modern data stack uh we sort of
think of it as how do you make these
tools and people work well together
while embracing the diversity and so
that is the and we'll talk about the why
we think the metadata activation layer
is
why why you do that but that's that's
sort of the approach that we're taking
here
all right um
and i work primarily on data hub it's an
open source the number one open source
metadata platform for the modern
postmodern legacy data stack and a lot
of people don't know what a metadata
platform is and we'll talk about a lot
of concepts here but our goal really is
to map
every single data concept known to an
enterprise in one comprehensive and
understandable metadata graph and then
everyone prospers so that's our goal
uh so my project is
sort of leading data science for
astronomer and in fact um
i was telling some friends just now i
got i got off a call
literally before this meeting where we
had a very contentious discussion about
what the definition of a closed
opportunity was
um and also like monthly active view
things like that and everybody is
looking at the data team to define what
those things mean which is sort of an
enviable position and also very
unpleasant um
so i was thinking that i'd probably
answer the question what is a data set
by saying i don't know uh somebody else
um
but i think that actually points at
something you there's i think a dry
definition of a data set right a
collection of observations stored in
some sort of digital format or something
but i think what's changed um if you
actually see like this pickup in the use
of the term data set around 2010 and i
think that's sort of the rise of the
data scientist and the idea that the
data set itself is like this
this locus of value
that it didn't used to be it used to be
just this annoying thing you had to
unpack and pass around from within one
tool to the next but now i think it's
it's
it's deliberately contentious it's
deliberately the focus of an
organization because there's so much
value in there
thank you i think the the notion of the
way that we see the world affecting how
we
understand the concepts that we all
encounter is is very central um
i guess before we dive much deeper into
definitions i i wonder if you could each
share
a story from your past professional
experience that you think most
significantly affected the way that you
have chosen to define
the data sets in in your tools today
maybe i can go first
so i
actually did not start my life in data
or at least data as most people
here define it a lot of you folks are
data engineers or data scientists and so
you're you're starting with data
after it's gotten to the warehouse
but i started my life working on data as
a database builder so i was actually
part of the linkedin data infrastructure
team and my job was
oracle is not keeping up with linkedin's
traffic we need a new
data store a source of truth data store
so i had to go build
a mongodb like document oriented
database for linkedin to run
the entire site
and so for me
a data set started out as a table in an
operational data store
and then later on i went on to build etl
for that distributed database and i
ended up also working on a change
capture system kind of like dibysium it
was called data bus
and i also worked with the kafka team
and so i ended up spending a fair bit of
time in the streaming ecosystem and that
affected kind of the understanding of a
data set as something that's in motion
and downstream of maybe the operational
data set
and then the last six years of my time
at linkedin i was actually the tech
architect for all of data platform big
data platform that kind of stuff
and so i realized that actually what i
thought of as data
was
something that the data warehouse team
didn't even care about they were talking
about data sets and golden data sets and
microstrategy dashboards and a bunch of
these other things and so that really
expanded my definition of what is a data
set it's actually all of the above even
a search index is actually a data set to
a search engineer
but then as you go down the stack and
you work with the metrics platform team
that's actually producing metric data
sets
there's like a bunch of more insights
that's
inside of these derived data sets
so that's kind of what has shaped my
definition of a data set and data hub's
definition of a data set we kind of talk
about tables and topics and key value
stores and metrics all as kind of data
sets
and the thing that
recently i've been thinking about the
most is
is a view a data set
because a view is code
and it transforms a data set so to an
orchestrator it could be something that
is a pipeline that they're materializing
but then for a consumer of that view
they just look at it like a data set
because it just gives them tuples so i
think that's kind of the most
interesting part of where i think data
sets are going
for me personally and as a project
yeah i guess
i feel like my
definition of an understanding of this
world has evolved over a very
heterogeneous career so what you said
really resonates about you know i
haven't spent my entire career in this
domain
and
you know
it's the heterogeneity that strikes me
and that's why we talk about data assets
and how
you know
and art you know i kind of started out
with the software definition but what it
really is is anything where you capture
information of the world in a durable
form
where you can ask questions and make
decisions based on it
so
a data asset is really almost a
decision-making engine
either directly in an automated machine
learning system or indirectly with
humans making decisions based on data
and yeah just seeing like you know i
used to work in healthcare and you know
surveying and talking to so many
different users with the extreme
heterogeneity of their use cases um all
the way from machine learning like and
that's why again like i think the
definition should be more general
i can go next
so
i ended up stumbling upon the world of
data
in some ways and self-taught
myself data so
i started out saying hey there are these
large scale problems in the world like
national health care and poverty
alleviation they don't seem to be using
data it feels like they should let's go
do something about that
and this was before the notion of a data
team was really a thing i think the word
data scientist was you know still one of
the sexiest things back and i think that
article had just come out uh right and
so it was very early in in the world um
and so we sort of started putting
together these teams to solve these big
problems are there so um
and what i ended up finding was that
every time we would have the most
successful projects it was when we had
these fundamentally very very different
people in the room like there was this
one time where we had to basically
figure out how to allocate
like lpg gas centers or clean energy
centers to 80 million women below below
the poverty line
and in the room we had data scientists
and data engineers and machine learning
engineers but we also had a program
manager who came from a political
science background who is like hey this
is the way you should think about how
these datasets should actually operate
like this is the wrong way that you're
thinking about you know building out
this this model for example
um and
the core thing about this was was just
that fundamental diversity data operates
at the intersection of technical and
business uh that's the core that's the
reality of data which basically means
that you need very different skill sets
to make these projects successful
but that actually is our biggest
strength but also our biggest weakness
because
can you hear me now
okay um
[Music]
uh so that's also the biggest weakness
right because if you think about
uh trust in a team most other teams are
built by people who know what each other
are working on
but in a data team when you know a
business analyst doesn't actually know
what a data engineer does on a daily
basis and that causes like a breakage of
trust in these teams when things go
wrong
and so
my overall thought process and this has
evolved into saying then if diversity is
the only reality in this team
how do we think about the core assets in
this case of data i said to a data
engineer what might matter the most is
did the pipeline break or not is the
data updated to a business user what it
means is like what does annual recurring
revenue actually mean
and these two people need to collaborate
well together to actually make a project
successful and so that fundamental
diversity is i think what is the only
reality that in a team and the way that
we think about data assets or data sets
uh sort of comes from there
yeah maybe i have a story that echoes a
few of those themes and expands on what
shoshanka was saying um i was working
with uh height well with toshiba um
high-tech manufacturer producing wafers
of memory chips and the wafer goes
through the factory the fab uh and it's
this multi-week very sort of weirdly
organic process and at the other end
becomes this disk of wafers of chips and
you want to know if it's successful or
not crudely speaking sort of a binary
classification good way for a bad wafer
and all along that journey you have
thousands of sensors making pressure
measurements temperature measurements
and so on uh and there are thousands of
those being taken every millisecond or
every minute depending on the thing so
you literally millions of sort of input
variables if you like you know this
sensor measured this at this time uh
that are potentially predictive of
whether the wafer's successful or not um
so toshiba referred to this as the six
million problem because essentially
you're sort of regressing
this binary outcome against six million
variables and that's not an easy thing
to do especially if you want the model
that does that to reflect the current
state of the fab at any given hour say
because it's constantly changing and
these wafers pulling them off early can
save you millions of dollars anyway
so that data set right that the factory
is creating was essentially a streaming
data set of sensor
information and then finally appended
with the success flag um so from the
point of view of the factory manager
this is a streaming data set from the
point of view of the
the engineer who's taking care of ingest
it lands in a hbase table i think it was
a set of name value pairs but from the
point of view of the data scientists
that's no good because that's just
unwieldy and also data scientists want
everything to be a table
um like a real table with lots of
columns um so there was this process
where you had to essentially do this
sort of dimensionality reduction to
still encode all of the information the
original data set would make that useful
to the data scientist and then you make
your prediction and then that's revealed
to the
um essentially back to the factory
manager to say this wafer failed for
this reason go and clean that machine
literally they would go there with a
bottle of windex or something and clean
the machine anyway the point is right
this is exactly about this idea of a
data set can be manifested at any single
point as name value pairs in hbase table
and
pandas data frame whatever it might be
but it's actually the same data set it
largely speaking contains the same
information this idea that a data set
can morph over time and can manifest
itself to different people in different
ways and therefore well it's a little
self-serving but you need that sort of
lineage component right you need you
need this idea of how these things
relate to each other i think that's
that's the key realization to me one of
the reasons i got interested in
orchestration because it's like oh you
need to tie these things together
that's even that that absolutely mirrors
a lot of my experience as well
specifically this notion that like a
data set
changes a lot and at the same time i
think there's a lot of discussion about
versioning data sets um and the need to
be able to have immutable data sets and
and sort of change this notion of a data
set transitioning into a notion of
lineage
i guess
what i want to do next is ask for
everyone everyone here to imagine a
single pane of glass view
of a data set
you know the ideal picture of
what you need to know in order to be
able to really understand and use a data
set and i'm curious for a couple things
one is what is there like what do you
see when you're looking at that pane of
glass and two where do you go to get
that picture
well
spoiler alert
you go to the orchestrator
um but i think just to vibe off what you
were saying to make uh uh the the notion
that it's the same data set as it flows
through the orchestrator i actually
fundamentally disagree with that um
because i think by the definition of a
data sets where you encode understanding
of the world effectively what's
happening is data flows through these
systems as you're you're changing your
understanding of the world and what's
doing that is the code it's like a human
wrote code and it changes the
understanding of the world from you know
it goes from data set a there's code and
data set b is different because there's
understanding that's built into that
which is why
we think that you know our belief
in the dagster project is that and we
have a new product direction additional
product direction that that really
doubles down on this that
the canonical place to define an asset
is in software
you write an asset in software it
declares it's in you're intending it to
exist over time
and you have a software artifact where
you can hang off all the different
metadata about it anything about it and
there's one system of record for that
um so what you want to understand is two
things at the same time
one is the software definition of that
data asset
and that's what the
programmer or the developer the
practitioner declares what they intend
the world to be like and then
simultaneously in that single pane of
glass
you also have a history of how that's
been materialized over time
and having that duality in one spot we
think is critical because that can
capture the intents and like what the
current state of lineage is as well as
for example the historical lineage which
has changed over time
so
i completely agree and disagree
nice let's do let's go so so completely
agree about the principles but you're
going to go to data hub because that's
the glass pane
but let me let me explain i think
the glass pane is really for humans to
get essentially like a 360 degree view
of the data set uh i mean a lot of us
talk about customer 360 right and i
think for the metadata world what we
want to see is data set 360. and what
does that contain it contains obviously
the basic stuff like the name of the
data set and the
schema of the data set and where it came
from and all of that stuff and ideally
if you're living in the data mesh world
or in a software defined data asset
world you are declaring your data assets
up front
which is awesome so you get that and
that's the definitional plane of that
thing but then there's the operational
plane of when
things actually run and being able to
get every single breadcrumb of
not just the daxter runs or the airflow
runs or the ml flow runs but also the
great expectation runs or the streaming
kafka connect runs or the you know the
queries that are going up against the
microservice instances just getting that
operational plane integrated and then
being able to move up that cognition
plane into the business world which is
where the customer and the revenue and
all of these models live
that i think is really what all of us
are really trying to give
to
the organizations a way to get not just
broad but also deep insights into
a data set as an anchoring entity
the other thing that i wanted to bring
up is we often get obsessed with the ux
of it all like the glass pane we think
of it as
an iphone like experience but there's
also the
developer plane
which is
um how do
programs or code integrate with this
pane of glass and what does that look
like and i think there's basically this
missing api 360
that is needed
so that any time in your jupiter
notebook when you need the schema of a
data set who are you going to call
anytime you need business metadata in
context who are you going to call
and that i think is for me
solving both of those would be great for
the industry
so i completely agree and disagree
um so here's where i agree i think that
the uh and we spend a lot of time
thinking about this concept of data 360
right and so you know engineer when you
onboard an engineer you should link to a
github repo it has your code your
documentation your divisions everything
in that same space
why do you know sales teams have a sales
force account id that they share why do
data teams not have that right and so
as you think about context context is
about how do you get context from every
single aspect of the ecosystem and bring
it to create almost that unique data
asset profile inside an organization but
here's where i disagree
i believe there is there actually isn't
a single pane of glass for every single
user it isn't the same single pane of
class for every single user uh because
context means very different things for
very different people uh context for
a business user is very different from
context for a data engineer the way
these people want to consume context is
also very different like i'm in a looker
dashboard i'm like huh can i trust this
dashboard what does this metric mean i
do not want to jump into a different
tool to actually get that context right
context for a data engineer is also very
different and the the time that you're
using this context if you're using this
when you're you know troubleshooting
something versus you're using this uh
when you're actually running an analysis
project that is the unique thing that
actually drives the way people or users
use this so the way so we think about
this is then if you can say hey netflix
has unique personalized experiences for
each and every one of us why can we not
create that
that same sort of personalized
contextual experience for every user um
one element of this the way we see this
in atlanta is we have this this concept
of personas and purposes so very unique
experiences for a analyst an engineer
but a marketing analyst and a financial
analyst
but the other way that you know we think
about this is we think about the
metadata activation layer is one aspect
of this is bringing this context and
stitching together that profile
the other aspect is taking it back to
the tools that people are using every
day um so if you're using looker
everyday you should get the context
right there in looker um if you're using
you know text or astronomer every day
you should get that context that you
need to troubleshoot those pipelines
right then and there right and so that's
the final layer that we think of which
will actually like you know you don't
need a single pane of glass what you
need is a better way for your team to
work together um and so how do you make
that happen um and that's where the
metadata activation layer um is will
hopefully reach its true promise in the
next couple of years
i agree with everything that everybody
has said actually i
maybe i won't try to make a broader
statement but i'll just say something
super specific because in a way this is
the problem i wrestle with and i was
referring to in the
my sort of intro right about sort of
working with all these different
departments and defining what an mau is
or whatever
and so i have a very boring answer to
this which is that
i realize that it's important for my
team right now to have strict and
well-publicized definitions of the
fields and the metrics and the kpis that
we create and most of those this will
probably change over time but most of
them right now live in a data warehouse
a traditional data warehouse
even the stuff that the data scientists
use
they may create a model out of it that
then scores but even that largely is
batch and will end up back in the data
warehouse so i insist
that every time
we create a data set in that warehouse
you add comments in the metadata that
the data warehouse supports it's created
at the time that you create the data set
we've got utility functions that
essentially in our internal airflow
implementation force you to do that but
it means that there's one source of
truth and it's not removed from the data
it literally lives in the comments for
the column in the table so it's a very
practical approach to defining these
things but there is one source of truth
there
this is a good so we've got this notion
that there needs to be a source of truth
um i think that uh we're clearly i think
pretty roundly rejecting the notion in
my question that there is a single pane
of glass for where that source of truth
uh is located which i which i i
appreciate and of course i don't think i
got to properly advocate for the notion
that the single source of truth is your
data quality framework so let me just
make sure i get that
on the record officially here
um i you know the corollary to this
question really is like who's
responsible for updating like stephen i
think you just said that you know it
needs to be the responsibility of
whoever is is uh changing a system to
update that definition which i have to
admit sounds a little bit like an
unfunded mandate right we all insist
that the person changing something
produce better documentation and yet the
world is is
all about finding ways to make that
easier to do so what are the what are
the uh or what what characteristics do
you think really
define the responsibility for updating
and how do you make sure that that
documentation stays accurate in any kind
of modern data stack
well to put on my recovery hat
i thought that was an excellent answer
that it really is a multi-stakeholder
problem
and i think
one of the challenges of these systems
is that they are multi-stakeholder you
have to think about how the different
personas are going to interact
um
so you know we really focus on the
engineering problem
and therefore
from that perspective the source of
truth should be in code
um we know how to deal with code code
review we know how to version it track
it etc so like for example this is
example of like the comments should be
in the column and co-located the
metadata should be in the warehouse
totally agree but i actually think the
source of truth should be in software
and it should automatically be reflected
in the in the data warehouse so it's a
question of like all this information
gets replicated all over the place but
the i think the interesting question is
for each particular piece of metadata
data or whatever is where is that source
of truth from which everything else is
derived
um and so you know kind of
whenever the engineer's in the loop
push it towards code you know then you
get into the world of different contexts
there's more in atlanta's domain of
you know
humans in the loop and workflow and all
that stuff and then for that aspect it
makes sense for that to be the source
the truth and maybe to pipe it back to
the other system so i really thought
your comments were super insightful
about the different contexts that
we work in i think you would totally mow
my hat i don't have anything to add to
that i fully agree
well who's acquiring who yeah
i mean
the notion that um you know that code is
the definitive source uh certainly i
think it's a pretty provocative thesis
in a in a very data centric world um and
so i guess before i i dive too deep on
that i want to to zoom out and think
about
what other kinds of metadata do you
think exist for which there already is
some clear emerging standard and which
ones do you think there is the most
daylight between systems
stephen i guess i'm going to direct this
to you specifically with respect to
lineage
yeah i think um
it's it's difficult to claim
notwithstanding the excitement of the
day that there is a single
uh
sort of standard for metadata um
what i think is true is that there are
winners and losers
and that the set of winners that sort of
bubble up that sort of emerge is pretty
finite
there's sql
there's python
there's
i don't know parquet there's sort of
relational tables um it's a finite list
and it's the responsibility i think
maybe of the orchestrators and the
lineage providers of the world to sort
of understand all those different
interfaces and collect them together so
nick's absolutely right the orchestrator
is sort of a natural
the orchestrator the data catalog these
are all natural places for that
information to belong we don't have to
pick or choose um but what we
have a responsibility to do is to
understand that there is this longish
but finite list and understand that but
there is no single metadata standard i
mean if there's there is it's probably
sql but it's not really metadata so
there just isn't one and that's telling
us something so don't force it to happen
you know
and one of the things i've noticed
especially around this kind of source of
truth debate as well as the
standardization
attempts
is that
while each individual producer of
metadata is extremely confident about
the metadata that it is producing
the
from a consumption perspective
you run into similar quality issues that
you face in data quality so for example
s3 might tell you
definitively that a particular file
lives in a particular bucket
but that doesn't tell you what the data
set is
or
who owns it or things like that
and for that you might need to actually
kind of cohere
your understanding of the glue catalog
plus s3 and in some cases you might also
need to consult athena which has an
external table reference to the same
glue catalog and so you've got different
kind of producers of metadata that are
very precise and opinionated about what
they're saying about a subset of the
graph
but i think there's a responsibility
that falls to a standardization layer
to say
does this data set exist and what does
it look like
and so far i think that responsibility
has sort of fallen on
the catalog or the metadata platform
and we can call it whatever we want but
there is the need for this kind of
standardization layer and so even if
we follow
a particular protocol in terms of
emitting metadata
there still is
a missing gap of saying
the syntax is right and it conforms to a
particular format
but
where's the semantics and how do i
standardize it for anyone to consume and
that i think is kind of an open
challenge that all of us are sort of
facing
well i think we've we've covered a lot
of ground um and i think from the very
beginning the the question of what is a
data set one of the themes that i really
heard from from everyone here is that
the the data set is the thing that we
can go to to answer questions like it is
the the you know however it is
instantiated or manifest it's the way
that we can have a shared
way of reconciling between
between different
groups and stakeholders i think we also
sound like really are describing this
notion that there is another data set at
least one data set then that exists
about all the other data sets
um whatever form that takes
what i want to do now as we wrap up here
is ask for for ichi we talked about uh
the things that you all agreed and
disagreed pretty vehemently with other
people here
can you just tell me what is uh your the
favorite sentence you've heard from
someone else on the panel today
uh well i already i can go first
because that way my favorite line will
not get taken
um so i really like the software defined
um asset definition that um nick talked
about because it it fits very closely
with kind of what i would like the world
to move towards which is definitions are
the source of truth and you define it as
close to
the
place where you're defining data itself
the world doesn't need bad metadata
quality we've suffered enough bad data
quality as it is and the more we can
push context up into the developers ide
the the better
it'll be for everyone whether it's
daxter or dbt or like pick your favorite
you know place where you live that's
fine but just do it there
and that's
for me that was kind of the best thing
for me but thank you
so nice
um i i will double down on what i said
about pruculpo's uh framing of rejecting
the framing of a single pane of glass
and says there's multiple overlapping
ones based on context i thought that was
very insightful
yeah that was that was going to be mine
as well i think it's absolutely true but
um so instead i'll give one to nick
which is this idea that the orchestrator
is also in itself in its own way the
source of truth and again it's so
self-serving but i think that's really
true that the data catalog or the
comments in snowflake wherever it is
tells you what this is at least
according to somebody's opinion but then
the first question that any marketer is
going to have is like well i'm not sure
i believe that or how did you calculate
that and you have to be able to go back
and not just look at the lineage but
look at actually how the calculations
happen to be able to verify that so
that's yours
i'm going to say um
actually what what sri shankar said
about the concept of a data 360
and i actually want to take that one
step further um on what
i think there's something very profound
that right which is
can we learn from what other teams have
been able to do uh so if you know
there's you know there are good things
that salesforce did with sales teams and
they're good things that you know figma
does with design teams and so are there
things that we can learn from other
teams and sort of bring that into our
and not just i know we talk a lot about
engineering and how to bring engineering
practices into data but can we think
about there are actually things that
business teams have done pretty well and
can we bring those practices into data
so that's um
thank you
in fact i think it's not just 360 which
is a 2d concept but it's actually 4d
because you actually want time which is
the other dimension to actually
understand the full context of a data
set
well thank you all very much for this
conversation it's been an absolute blast
to get to be up here uh with with you
and to be in front of this audience i'm
really excited about what we've gotten
to cover and i think you know there's
certainly a lot that we all get to go
look forward to now as we build on these
ideas and continue to
build the the modern data stack together
and uh continue to evolve and hash out
the ways that all of the parts interact
thanks very much
[Applause]